US President Donald Trump has kicked off
Independence Day celebrations at an
event in South Dakota fireworks lit up
the sky over the Mount Rushmore Monument
which in a controversial move Trump
chose as the venue for this is
festivities in a divisive speech he
criticized recent protests against
racial injustice as a merciless campaign
to wipe out our history Trump made
little reference to the corona virus
pandemic though his speech came on a day
the u.s. saw another record rise in
cases with more than 50,000 57,000 sorry
new infections the US president promised
a tremendous celebration to mark
Independence Day positioned under the
watchful gaze of some of the country's
most influential leaders Trump linked
his presidency to defending their legacy
I am here is your president to proclaim
before the country and before the world
this monument will never be desecrated
these will never be defense their legacy
will never ever be destroyed their
achievements will never be forgotten
and Mount Rushmore will stand forever as
an eternal tribute to our forefathers
and to our freedom the trip to South
Dakota came amid heightened racial
tensions a time of national reckoning
over the symbolism of monuments with
ties to slavery there is a growing
danger that threatens every blessing our
ancestors fought so hard for struggled
they bled to secure our nation is
witnessing a merciless campaign to wipe
out our history to fame our heroes erase
our values and indoctrinate our children
of the four presidents depicted on Mount
Rushmore - were slave-owners
in recent weeks statues in their honor
and the legacy they represent have been
questioned Trump accused the movement
seeking to tear down these monuments of
purging America of its true history for
hundreds of Native American activists
and their supporters US history is
problematic they were pushed back by
riot police on the road to Mount
Rushmore ahead of the president's
arrival on indigenous land taken by the
US government it's clear Trump's view of
mount Rushmore's history remains at odds
with theirs
well all around the United States fourth
of July fireworks displays and parades
have been canceled due to fears of a
further spread of the virus with experts
calling on Americans to practice social
distancing at public and private
gatherings not many feel like
celebrating the national holiday
GWS Oliver sallet has more last chance
to enjoy an empty Washington law before
the celebrations begin this is where
large crowds will cheer to flyovers and
fireworks on America's national holiday
the loudspeakers are ready for tens of
thousands of visitors but not everyone
here feels well about being among masses
of people at the height of a global
pandemic it makes me anxious to be like
around the crowd to be honest so that's
why I want to be going out but I think I
think it it's definitely a kind it sucks
that you know we won't be able to
celebrate the way we used to those past
years but we're gonna try to make the
most of it with you know family and
close friends that we've been kind of
quarantined with during the last few
months this year the fourth of July will
be a completely different holiday number
one because a security fence was set up
here keeping people away from the White
House for security reasons as we're
expecting many protests potentially
riots on the fourth of July and later on
Saturday this is where the president
will deliver his speech addressing the
nation at the black lives matter Plaza
t-shirt vendors are hoping for good
business and a large turnout
independence all the liberties that we
have achieved from over 200 years and
should apply to everyone
and obviously this demonstration shows
it's really not equal for everyone I
just hope that more and more people will
wear those masks because that is so
critical at this point a holiday under
strain by the pandemic and racial
divisions this year not everyone feels
like celebrating
DW report at William blue Kraft has been
looking into this story and he joins me
now William thanks for coming in public
health experts in the u.s. a warning of
a heightened risk of the virus spreading
over this long weekend celebrations the
White House appears to be largely
ignoring those recommendations or at
least not not setting a very good
example why is that I mean Donald Trump
only mentioned the virus once at the
very beginning of his speech and he
wasn't that accurate about it he thanked
medical workers for working to kill the
virus but difficult to kill something
that's not really alive but it fits with
Donald Trump's language rhetoric of
violence of aggression of law and order
you know the twelve administration would
say we are following the rules the rules
are recommended masks not every state
has the same rule South Dakota has no
distancing or mask masks mask rules
those rules are really only in place in
about 20 states plus Washington DC and
the Trump administration Donald Trump
has himself has said this is a state's
issue this is not on us it's a good way
to sidestep that that prickly question
of what exactly is the best way to
confront this virus and to ignore the
very real situation on the ground that
cases are skyrocketing throughout the
United States and that's what we saw
yesterday even though the corona virus
has hit home in the Donald Trump family
the girlfriend of Donald Trump jr. who's
also a campaign adviser tested positive
for that virus but instead of focusing
on the virus as you mentioned he said he
made only one reference to it in the
speech President Trump accused
protesters at racial equality
demonstrations of campaigning to wipe
out our history that's a quote
let's take a listen to what he had to
say there is a growing danger that
threatens every blessing our ancestors
fought so hard for struggled they bled
to secure our nation is witnessing a
merciless campaign to wipe out our
history to fame our heroes erase our
values and indoctrinate our children
quite divisive words William what do you
make of what he had to say I mean this
is Donald Trump doubling down on being
Donald Trump heading into the heart of
the campaign season before the November
election appealing to the very core base
of his of his supporters he has long
known for using divisive rhetoric
racially coded rhetoric like he did here
I mean saying that America will not
stand for this kind of destruction this
kind of protests of some other them but
the them he's referring to her also
American so very divisive rhetoric and
you know for him to say that this is not
American history that American has
actually been destroyed this is
absolutely American history American
history is of fighting and bleeding and
dying to uphold the rights that have
been on paper for now almost 250 years
when he talks about the Declaration of
Independence and all the rights that the
founding fathers gave to all Americans
that of course didn't happen right then
it's been happening over the last 200 in
almost 50 years through a lot of
struggle and a lot of pain which we're
seeing up to this day with all the
protests taking place on streets all
around the country I wanted to wait and
see what happens over the weekend but
William grew glue craft thanks very much
for coming in
you